welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and we have a new loki trailer from
the marvel disney plus series i
am most stoked to see i literally woke
up to this over here on the west coast
there was an earthquake in the middle of
the night turns out that was just
loki arriving in this timeline so here
i'm gonna do my quick bra reaction to
this trailer some of the big highlights
start to explain
what this madness is and then sometime
later i'm gonna be able to go through
this shot by shot frame by frame for all
the easter eggs that we missed in
meantime here we
go
oh she's got it okay so this is right
after this place is
the timekeepers have built quite the
circus
and i see the clowns are playing their
parts to perfection
big metaphor guy i love it makes you
sound super smart
i am smart i know okay okay
please sign to verify this is everything
you've ever said this is
this looks so good we protect
the proper flow of time
you picked up the tesseract breaking
reality
oh i want you to help us fix it i'd love
a timeline
mommy i need your unique low-key
perspective
you really believe in this loki variant
luckily he believes in himself enough
for the both of us
it is adorable that you think you could
possibly
manipulate me
i'm ten steps ahead of you
you're not big on trust are you
you can trust me i've studied almost
every moment of your entire life
you've literally stabbed people in the
back like 50 times
i'd never do it again
oh my god god bless this god of mischief
i uh you know folks when i see trailers
like this uh there's a part of me that
gets so
freaking excited for all the goodies
that are hidden in it another part of me
goes
great that's how i'm gonna spend the
next 18 hours
whatever it's a labor i love because i'm
telling you just in the production
design the the quirky props the weird
bureaucratic
layout of the tva every aspect of the
show looks like it was
informed by some humorous douglas adams
style choice
you're gonna see a lot of parallels with
rick and morty that's because a lot of
the writers on this show they're trying
to make a
rick and morty type show within the mcu
now just to answer some questions right
out the bat
this uh this female character that loki
is sitting with a lot of people are like
is that natasha romanov on vermeer is
loki gonna resurrect black widow or save
her from an alternate timeline no no
this is not scarlet joe hits and this is
sophia dimartino's character
whom many of us believe to be a female
version of loki called lady loki from
the comics that's kind of the
incarnation loki becomes after the
ragnarok event in the comics this isn't
going to be an exact adaptation there's
there's probably going to be a lot of
different comic influences that are
brought in here but notice how in this
trailer they talk about do you trust
this loki variant
which suggests there could be infinite
different loki variants out there now in
this multiverse
and that one of those variants could be
this lady loki could be the antagonist
of the series but before we continue
thank you to bang energy for sponsoring
this video
every can of bang energy has zero
calories zero carbs zero sugars and zero
artificial flavors each
16 ounce can contains 300 milligrams of
caffeine
super creatine coq10 and bcaas
i am sipping on rainbow unicorn not like
those thundercloud unicorns the unicorns
that make you feel happy when you sip
them it's just
sweet and light like you're on the back
of a unicorn leafing over a more
depressed unicorn
i honestly rely on bangs when i'm
shooting those early morning after shows
and i don't want my eyes to look like
i'm half asleep when i'm trying to break
down these easter eggs i need my mind to
be alert check out bang on instagram you
can get 10
off your order at dangenergy.com when
you use the code new rockstars 10.
rainbow there you can buy a variety pack
of bang energy or grab a 12
pack of citrus twist bankster berry the
new delish
strawberry kiss use my code new
rockstars 10 and receive 10
off your bang energy order that's code
new rockstars 10 for 10
off it's also interesting that the tva
blames loki in particular for breaking
the timelines they kind of identify that
as the nexus point him stealing the
tesseract and escaping from the avengers
time heist
as if everything else the avengers did
was okay whereas no i mean captain
america
supposedly returned all the stones
somehow to their point in which they
were taken
which we already know that would have
been hard enough to pull off but thanos
all of his army they disappeared from
the 2014 timeline in order to fight the
avengers in the main 2023 timeline
so there's a whole timeline that exists
where thanos doesn't exist but maybe the
tva identifies that as like
the first kind of screw-up that happened
that was unable to be patched so they're
hoping that the god of mischief who
seems to be a character who might be a
nexus being as
you know it was suggested by wanda
maximoff in one division he might be
kind of detached from all different
timelines and that's why owen wilson's
character mobius immobius identifies him
as a good asset in order to patch
everything back together yeah i'm loving
this timeline screen
yeah the one that they focus on is kind
of splitting off further
you can tell that there are several
others that are snaking off that looks
like they were doing that before
loki's snaked off so it wasn't so much
loki it was the entire time heist that
did this from end game and they're just
blaming loki because they're the ones
that they can get their hands on but
also the one who could practically help
them fix it
so initially it seems like loki's
helping the tva try to capture this
rogue variant who's further screwing
everything up in the time stream
and that investigation leads them it
looks like to a renaissance fair you can
see a booth there that says festival
maps
and then to the supermarket rocks cart
which could be a futuristic supermarket
with like by and large in the pixar
wally movie
inside this place there's like a gaming
section and missions like alien gaming
which
just seems like a very rick and morty
thing i love it but during this
collaboration loki escapes and that's
where the madness begins because we know
the show is going to feature loki
jumping around to different points in
history
affecting them kind of filling in the
gaps of historical mysteries we knew
about so in the previous trailer we know
that he's going to be d.d cooper that's
the that's mystery plane hijacker who
demanded 200 thousand dollars up in
oregon
hijacked a flight to washington and then
jumped out the middle his remains were
never found
the answer to that mystery blokey and
then as i pointed out the last trailer
there was a place that loki was at where
it's at 79 a.d
and making me think that that could be
the city of pompeii and there is a shot
in this trailer where loki seems to be
standing in a volcanic eruption just
going like ah you almost got me
this script of everything lookie has
said in his life is so funny to me
because i kid you not
this is a guy i would be in the mcu i
try to keep a list of everything every
character says so i can use it against
him in future theories
so if like wandavision this show kind of
makes fun of the nerds who look too much
into things i'm here for it and based on
we know from these other trailers
in some of this alternate timeline
meddling we might be visiting a timeline
where loki's able to become president of
a post-apocalyptic earth we also know
that he's revisiting the 2012 battle of
new york maybe there's a version of that
timeline where he's victorious the
chitauri army dominates the planet and
then
in that aftermath loki is able to become
president or at least runs for president
there's like a comic series that
inspires that as well so i've said it
before this is kind of the
wacky time heist that i wanted the
second active end game to be and game
was kind of restrained by
its own story arcs and i understand that
i don't fault it for that but
i kind of want to just live in the
madness of when people screw with
history and that's what this loki show
is giving me it's gonna feel like doctor
who it's gonna feel like uh quantum leap
and rick and morty in all the best ways
so a schedule update here i am gonna do
a frame by frame breakdown of everything
in this trailer i feel like there's so
many clues here
but this is a big one it's gonna take me
a lot of time we have a couple other
projects that we have to get to first
including a full breakdown of godzilla
versus kong i love that movie and i love
the breakdown we did of it i'm so
excited to share it with you guys
and a few other things so just give us
some patience this breakdown will be out
soon in the meantime you can check out
our new anarchy assembled shirt at our
new rockstar's merch or norixers
merch.com follow me on instagram and
twitter at eavos
follow new rockstars and we'll see you
next time bye
[Music]
you